more products I don't use again a lot of
people have asked me about these and
this is personal to me I'm not saying
that no one should be using these
products with mi mi is a preservative
I'm allergic to if you're not allergic
to it then it isn't really a problem
until you become allergic but it is one
of the more allergenic ones I'm not
really allergic to a lot of stuff in
skincare but this is the one it makes me
itch and it's also in laundry detergent
so if you find that you're itchy with
some clothes and sheets and stuff that
might be something to look into products
with bad packaging it's not really
something you notice unless it's bad
like a squeezy tube with a super runny
product in it or a product that's just
too thick for the pump or if it like
violently flies out of the pump it's
just too stressful lash serums with
prostag gland and analoges this is stuff
that works like latis there are side
effects like they can change your eye
color and reduce the fat around your
eyes and make them look sunken it's
pretty crappy of Brands to put them in
there because they should really be
drugs it's not all lash serums but just
make sure that you look up the
ingredients before you buy one so you
know what you're getting into